Everyone, it's Jennifer Garner.
(audience applauding)
Hi Drew.
I can't believe I'm not there with you.
I just want to give you like a big old squeeze.
I remember the very first time I was in a room with you.
I ran right over to you.
In fact, I think we have a picture of it.
I mean, literally, I look like I'm meeting
my like, big-crush in life, and I was.
And I was so excited also, because that was,
around let's see 2004 was definitely "Charlie's Angels" era
for me, and coming out of it,
and you were doing "Alias",
and it was so exciting.
I felt like it was hard to establish yourself
as a woman who wasn't trying to be a man,
if you were doing stuff that men did.
Exactly.
Well, you know, the whole reason I got so excited
about investing myself in stunts, and doing them all,
and learning to fight, and being on wires,
was because of "Charlie's angels".
Just because I was such an enormous fan
of what you guys did, and how you change the game.
And I ended up working with your same stunt crew.
(foreign language)
And I ended up working with those same guys
on a movie later, and was just like, "Tell me everything
they did. How did they train? What was it like?"
You're my inspiration, Drew.
Oh my gosh, you are my inspiration for so many things.
And, the way you are protective with your kids
and trying to create laws around
kids' protective stuff with paparazzi.
You've been such an activist.
How did you become such a good, grounded, realistic,
awesome, activist for kids?
Gosh, so I started working for Save The Children
12 years ago.
My daughter is 15.
And having grown up in West Virginia,
surrounded by rural, generational poverty,
and having a mom who grew up super poor in Oklahoma.
I realized that I really was looking for who's helping kids
like my mom, or like the kids that I grew up with.
I always say, I grew up one generation
and one holler removed from poverty.
But it touched me. I saw it.
I saw the inequality of opportunity,
and of just possibility for kids that I grew up with.
And I saw what a miracle my mom was
in her own circumstance.
And what a hero she has of her story.
And I just feel like, you need some help
to become the hero of your story if you have less.
So I did get to work for Save, really quietly for years,
I mean, years.
But then, eventually, once social media became a thing
and we all joined it,
which I went into kicking and screaming,
Save the Children said to me,
part of what you should be doing is,
not just sharing these stories in a room.
But share them with the world.
I know that I am genuinely trying to share my experience
because I think life is a communal experience.
And we are all equally in this time together.
And that's exactly what I smell from you.
(Drew sniffing)
It's just so genuine and I love watching it.
Yeah. I feel the same about watching you
when you have a tip about your kids,
or when you have an idea.
I feel like, "Oh man, I feel like I could try that."
Because, you couldn't be...
I know we could sit down right now,
and get real in about three seconds,
about our kids, about our lives.
That's just...
And what's the point otherwise?
What is the point of doing anything that isn't
coming from something?
(audience applauding)
Which is a huge part, I'm not trying to switch topics,
but, Once Upon a Farm had to fit inside the circle
of what I already had going on in my life.
I couldn't start a business,
that was something like totally out of the blue.
It had to be something that was all interconnected,
'cause it just feels goofy otherwise.
Like that is the farm that my mom grew up on.
Where she, you know, the little root cellar where she,
and hers, that's where me as an 11 year old,
with a cow named Jennifer.
(everyone laughing)
And at a certain point, it just made more sense
for it to be under my care.
And so, I had to buy it from my family.
But going back to try to find the paperwork,
it was bought on a handshake.
And it's incredible.
It's just the most special, full-circle gift
to have in in my little family's life.
That our little farm has come to life.
And is growing food for babies.
(audience applauding)
Does the control room have the picture of me.
I just sent you guys.
'Cause I tried to screen grab a video I made
while eating your Once Upon a Farm packet.
I'm genuinely on an airplane, just guzzling.
I remember. You don't even know.
It was such an incredible boost to all of us
to have your support for our little plant-based...
You know, we're just like this little deeky-deek...
Oh, but look.
This new blend kicks off our Save The Children partnership.
So, Once Upon a Farm is starting to, this year,
we're starting off with this blend,
but it's gonna expand next year.
And we're helping kids in America have access
to better nutrition, all in all ways.
You're a really solid human being.
And everything you take on in your life,
the way you handle it, I'm just like...
Oh my God, the thing that you talked
about with your kids writing a note.
About like, I want to grow up and what was it?
Be a fun killer?
This was legitimate.
This happened, this showed up on my desk.
When I grow up, I want to be a fun-killing mom
just like you.
(everyone laughing)
You know, Mom, why can't I ever do what I want to, mom?
That's my son.
I have to show those to my daughters
'cause they're just gonna love those.
And that's the kind of stuff that when you share it,
it's charming, and yet I'm like, " Oh okay,
my kids would definitely write a note like that too."
And, I've talked to a Aliza, who I know that you know.
I love that you share Aliza's wisdom with the world.
She is another level.
She's on the show today.
And not to put you on the spot,
but if you ever want to do something with the three of us,
The three of us, oh, we wouldn't get anything done.
But yeah, for sure.
Yes, that's perfect.
(everyone laughing)
(upbeat music)